mack contrajo pocas sorpresas más bien
más continuidad y sobre todo adaptado a
lo que está sucediendo actualmente en
europa en especial en términos de la
crisis energética en donde propone que
para 2050 ya francia no dependa de
energías fósiles además de esto habrá un
aumento también en el gasto de defensa
aunque no dio cifras precisas el otro
punto importante de este programa es la
educación en donde la mano de maicón
quiere que los maestros tengan una mejor
remuneración y anaya una inversión mucho
más importante en educación superior y
también en investigación por supuesto
hablo de esa reforma pensional y reiteró
su deseo de que la edad de pensión suba
a los 65 años tres años más de lo que
ella es actualmente pero eso esté
acompañado por un mínimo de jubilación
que estaría en los 1.100 euros en cuanto
a continuidad bueno la norma con quiere
un proyecto que se inscriba en el marco
de una sociedad mucho más igualitaria en
donde haya mayor protección de la
infancia y también donde el sistema de
salud sea mucho más eficaz en términos
de prevención las novedades vinieron más
cuando se refirió a la inmigración
unas reglas mucho más estrictas para
otorgar las visas de larga estadía y
para aquellas personas que hayan hecho
una petición de asilo y ésta le sea
denegada tendrán la obligación de salir
del territorio francés cierto es que
durante tres horas después de haber
presentado su programa de manuel mejor
respondió a las preguntas de los más de
300 periodistas que estaban aquí en esta
sala y mostró que en realidad conocen
los temas al derecho y al revés el que
sigue punteando en todos los sondeos
tanto en la primera la primera como la
segunda vuelta sin embargo se le
preguntó qué pasaría si ha pensado qué
pasaría si no llega a ganar dijo que por
ahora no se le ha atravesado esa idea
por la cabeza y que en caso de ser así
tendría que tomarse un tiempo antes de
saber qué haría después